Let me go next to our caller from the 3 1
2 area code who's calling today from 3 1 to.
Hi, David, this is Priscilla.
I'm from Chicago.
Hey, Priscilla, what's going on?
I'm just wondering, what's your take on this?
You know, there's a lot of Joe Biden sexual
assault allegations.
And I am not a Trump supporter.
I would never vote for him in my life.
But I honestly also don't feel comfortable
voting for someone who has had so many sexual
assault allegations.
And I honestly feel like at least some of
them are credible.
And yeah, I don't know how I feel about that.
So I'm aware we talked earlier about the terror
Reid allegations.
Which which other allegations are you referring
to?
I'm not sure of the name specifically, but
it's mostly just, you know, and my comfortable
voting for someone who even has the allegations
against them at all, because it's it's it
would be hypocritical of me to be like, oh,
I don't want to vote for Donald Trump because
he's a rapist or whatever, but then go and
vote for someone like Joe Biden, who's allegedly
done the same thing to other people.
But so is there any allegation other than
the terror Reid one that you're aware of.
I am not specifically aware of any other loan,
but I've heard that there are multiple allegations,
so maybe I'm just not informed about it.
Well, I think there's definitely people that
are.
There's definitely a blending together of
like Biden hugged a senator's daughter and
it was weird and the terror Reid thing.
So here's here's my view and I've sort of
stated it already, but here's how I think
it applies to voting at every woman's allegations
should be taken seriously and investigated.
What's Harry Reid is alleging is serious and
it deserves investigation.
She deserves to be heard.
This is my view, regardless of the political
party of accuser accused.
Whatever.
Period.
And full stop.
Where I would next go to is great.
You don't like.
You don't want to vote for anyone who's been
accused of anything like that.
Perfect.
The next question is, what else do you care
about?
Right.
In the sense that so Trump's been accused
by 16, 17, 22, 46 women, according to one
book.
We know that he's paid off some women, his
own wife under threat of perjury in a deposition,
accused him of raping her, etc.
And then we do have the terror Reid allegation
with Biden.
Where are you on climate?
Where are you on taxation?
Where are you on corona virus response?
Where are you on education?
Where are you on diplomacy?
Is there any difference there in terms of
your view on Trump versus Biden?
Oh, absolutely.
I mean, I just think Biden is stronger on
all those issues than Trump, and he's.
It goes back to what you always say.
You know, he it's kind of picking who I would
rather have, you know.
Right.
Not my ideal.
I voted for Bernie in the primary.
And I wish I could vote for him again in the
general.
However, I am still considering voting for
Biden just because I really don't want Trump
back in.
Right.
So another Priscila, is it?
Is there a good if I say to you, who do you
prefer, Trump or Biden?
Is there a clear answer in your mind?
By them, so.
So then is there any question about what you
should do in November?
There is still just because I don't know,
like he's just not the person I want.
And it goes back to, you know, do I really
want you know, it's so hard because I am pulled
in both directions like.
Yes.
I don't want Donald Trump.
I also don't want to just get fightin my vote
just because, you know, and Migliardi idea
of what the corporate Democrats are expecting.
It sounded like you were saying it's not just
because in other words, you said you preferred
Biden over Trump.
I listed six or seven policy issues and you
said Biden's better, right?
You said that about a minute ago.
Yeah, so it's not really just because it sounds
like you've analyzed their positions on policy
and you've decided which ones better.
Yeah, I have.
I just I don't know, I feel kind of I still
feel some hesitation and I'm not sure I still
feel like I will vote for him, but I know
I don't know and I know a lot of people are
in the same boat that they're just kind of
feeling.
I know it's like we're in a rock and a hard
place.
We're forced to vote for someone who we're
not completely behind, which I guess that's
kind of always the case.
Different degrees.
I mean, no, I'm not I've never voted for anyone.
I'm completely behind.
It's always who were you more behind?
And it sounds like you're pretty damn clear
about that.
Yeah.
I am now.
I am I've just been such a Bernie supporter
since Hijau and now this is gonna be my first
time voting.
Well, and yeah, it's just not the way I plan.
But thank you for your time.
Priscilla.
I can tell from talking to you that you're
gonna do the right thing in November.
Thank you.
All right, I'll take care of it.
All right.
I apologize for everybody I was not able to
get to.
We are out of time today, but we will take
calls again.
Really appreciate you joining me.
Quick break.